and then you throw in the bomb and
nothing else matters it's just violent
it's just violent
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Bobby Flay he's
Emmy award-winning food TV Pioneer and
acclaimed restaurateur catch him
Tuesdays on the Food Network with
Bobby's triple threat and then again on
Thursdays We Beat Bobby Flay he also has
a cat food lion called made by nacho and
of course Bobby's Burgers with locations
across the country Bobby Flay welcome to
the show so glad to be here this I feel
like I'm in an iconic uh seat right now
whoa coming from you that is such a
compliment what's going through your
head as you prepare to take on the uh
I'm definitely nervous for sure because
you know some people I think oh this is
going to be easy for him Chili Peppers
is his game he cooks for a living Etc
but
um this is gonna be tough I know it is I
I've seen some of the best uh take it
right on the chin
[Music]
thank you
here okay
[Music]
buffalo hot sauce mm-hmm
okay
so that's good flavor
[Music]
it's hot I mean I I have to say right
for the first one it's a little hotter
than I thought it was gonna be I know I
get that because I've seen a lot of your
guests and it's like you know the first
couple they're like all right you know
like warming up like this was the this
is the honey and maple syrup you know
part of the show but um that one a
little yeah see I see you guys are after
me I I know it I know my goal my goal is
to not curse during the show all right
well we'll see how that goes all right I
don't know if I'm gonna actually be able
to get through it because everybody
seems to swear on this show at some
point yeah I don't think they know
they're doing it no no but I'm gonna try
not to so it's rather remarkable to me
how prolific you've been as a figure in
food TV around for almost 30 years close
to two dozen shows by my account
is someone who's had a front row seat to
the meteoric rise in food television is
there an era that you would describe as
food TV's golden age I think the golden
age is now but Iron Chef our Iron Chef
changed the game it um it brought Food
Network into pop culture we went from
being just like the chef with a cook
behind the stove doing how to chop an
onion to this Insanity of competition
shows and I really believe that Iron
Chef and then Iron Chef America
um really changed the game
blistered shishito and garlic now you
know what they say about shishitos one
in every 10 is really spicy and the best
the rest aren't so it's a little
roulette who knows what's going on here
[Music]
thank you
very Savory I like that flavor
very nice
that one's less hot than the buffalo hot
sauce all kinds of Mind Games going on
over here Bobby oh you thought you knew
what you're getting yourself into right
so you think but yeah you think you're
going down one road but then you look at
the sign and it's like that's not the
road yeah no it's a wild ride welcome
before the Crazy Train bomb all right 20
done
but in your opinion is the best
restaurant movie of all time I like big
night one of my faves
um the last the very last scene of big
night watch it carefully the next time
you watch it there's no cut and Stanley
Tucci makes an omelet from scratch from
basically from from cracking the eggs to
scrambling them in a bowl to put them
putting them in the pan to making The
Omelette and serving his his brother in
the movie there's no cut in the in the
in the final scene it's a it's a
beautiful food scene and then there's
another movie that I really love it's
actually a German film
called mostly Martha and I think that
the food in that movie is spectacular
and it's something very romantic about
the entire about the entire thing
I can taste the passion fruit right away
[Music]
you know it has that that sort of nice
aromatic perfumey kind of flavor it's
definitely got Heat
that's got some warmth on it
how if at all do you think that your
first Iron Chef New York battle against
Morimoto how do you think that changed I
know you're gonna bring this up how do
you think that changed food television
um I well I really think that that was
that was the moment where we it brought
us into pop culture
um it was a crazy event you know I was
so overly hyped in my head to kind of do
a good job I almost cut my thumb off I
got electrically shocked I mean it was
lots of my mother was like crying in the
audience I mean it was it was a brutal
hour of cooking
um but uh the president of the Food
Network at the time a woman named Judy
Gerard who I'm still friendly with said
to me you took it on the chin for us but
I'll never forget it and it and and she
didn't and um that we then created Iron
Chef America I mean it was a very very
big moment for us
am I allowed to touch the bottle yeah
yeah
I don't know what the rules are there's
no rules I don't want to get shot in the
chair or the hot ones shoot you we're
fully in the uh abstract uh Los
Calientes Barbacoa Okay so
like this idea so this is probably gonna
have more of a like a red chili kind of
barbecue-ish yeah yeah hot sauce flavor
one two three four
you know
smokey
probably some Chipotle in there mm-hmm
one of my faves
[Music]
I like that nice and Smoky and fiery and
we actually would call it like a
Grilling and Chilling sauce oh really
yeah
delicious it's really really good
definitely got some heat and on the
topic is it true that you shot 42
episodes of Grilling and Chilling in
just six days six days it was either six
days or seven days I can't remember if
we did six a day or seven a day but it
was in that range and
um this is before Food Network had money
for editing I'm not kidding there was no
edit yeah talk me through this I'm fast
well we had to learn how to do TV live
to tape as they call it so like
today I'm making uh I'm making uh Los
Calientes chicken wings and when we come
back I'm gonna grill a red snapper with
coconut and red curry uh we'll be right
back you're watching grilling chilling
and then they'd go to Commercial and
then we'd come back and hey welcome back
to grill and chilling today we're making
this and that and the other thing and
then and then like you'd have to hit the
you'd have to hit the brakes they they
would put up a cue card that would say
like two minutes a minute 30 seconds and
then they'd count you down in ten nine
and then go to commercial so it taught
me how to do television very quickly and
I and it really actually helped me in
how I shoot TV today you know we should
Beat Bobby Flay we shoot two Prime Time
episodes basically by five o'clock in
the afternoon we're done and so I can do
50 episodes in 25 days it's great
okay this is a very different looking
hot I'm obsessed with it
I took a really big bite there I don't
know why
you're confident halfway mark
you're lonely whoa
hi
this is a I will say this though this is
a very delicious hot sauce it is I mean
it is so it's like filling my mouth with
flavor
death it grows a little bit you know it
grows definitely definitely Heat
but very herbaceous
it's Savory as well I feel like there's
like onions garlic maybe some shallots
in there or something I don't really
know but it's got a lot of flavor this
is delicious this is a really good sauce
it is it's Max and it's beautiful and
it's gorgeous to look at it just put it
on a shelf and be mesmerized by it
everybody's still here
I know no matter the heights of your
culinary Fame it'll always be important
to you to be a part of the everyday
conversation of where to eat New York if
aliens came down from space and landed
in Times Square alright and demanded to
be fed a quintessential dish from New
York what immediately comes to mind in
your opinion I always think of
steakhouses I think of like the classic
steakhouses Peter Luger's wolfgangs
things like that you know a big giant
porterhouse steak those crispy potatoes
cream spinach a big bottle of red wine I
mean to me that's the quintessential New
York
um New York meal I also think like you
know Southern Italian food uh is also a
very New York thing so like when you
like you see people like you know
begging to get into Carbone you know
because they want to eat like that you
know the rigatoni with the spicy vodka
sauce and they want to eat the shrimp
scampi and again not inexpensive but
it's it's an experience and it's a very
satisfying New York experience
thank you
this looks like a wine bottle
I always smell it first
yep yeah
see
ghost peppers
they're they're murderers yeah they
really are they're so like I remember
taking three
um
uh three
wait this is that moment where I can't
speak
I remember taking three uh what is coin
on the cobs and taking the corn off and
putting in a sauteing pan with a little
butter and I I'm not kidding Sean I I
like ate like a whisper full of whisper
full I'm following I'm following a tiny
tiny bit but a goat pepper on its own
it's like it's a weapon it's crazy
who have you found to be more brutal in
your experience restaurant reviewers or
TV critics I always feel like my my
apron in my restaurant or at home even
is my shield from the world and um it's
the place on the most comfortable it's
what I want to be doing I'm a cook at
heart I love to cook for my friends and
my family it's how I show my adoration
to them and um and so when a food critic
takes a shot at me in my restaurants I
take it really personally and I should
because it's my food and it's my
restaurant it's my creation sometimes I
feel like
I can somehow
justify like a shot from a from a TV
critic because I'm like oh it's it's the
production or you know it's or they
didn't like the lighting or they didn't
like my outfit that night or whatever it
is but uh the restaurant
um the restaurant critique hits harder
I'm always fascinated by these throwback
stories of like a New York Times
restaurant critic going in and like
disguise or with a decoy so that they
can have an anonymous dining experience
when you think about the critic hijinks
that you've seen up close and personal
is there a story that comes out knowing
every move of the current New York Times
restaurant critic was part of our job I
mean there's
pictures of them in the kitchen so that
everybody in the restaurant knows what
they look like when they come in we have
as many of their aliases as possible as
many of their phone numbers as possible
but the bottom line is knowing the New
York Times restaurant critic is is make
or break for your business
um you know and then there's this whole
song and dance that goes on when the
critic comes in and you make believe you
don't see him and he makes believe that
you don't know he's there and everybody
knows that you're there and it's a whole
thing but that's just the way it's
always been I mean I've had more dreams
and nightmares about New York Times
restaurant critics than anything else in
my life for sure
[Music]
mango lemongrass star anise interesting
what's the meat well
why am I taking such big bites because
we're here Bobby the chicken wings are
good you guys have good Chef here this
is good oh exam yeah
that's for you that's good
so I was fascinated to read somewhere
that restaurants that operate within
airports have to keep their chef knives
Tethered to a table for TSA guidelines
and you've expanded your empire into so
many unique places I just want to bounce
a few off of them I'm curious what comes
to mind when you think about the unique
or bizarre challenges of running a
business in each okay casinos
um I have a bunch of restaurants and
casinos I actually love having
restaurants and casinos because
especially like in Las Vegas there's an
amazing culture for the hospitality
industry a lot of people move to Las
Vegas to be in it so I have a lot of
really great professionals who work for
me there Yankee Stadium Yankee Stadium
so we have a Bobby's Burgers there I've
been a lifelong Yankee fan so for me to
have a place there is a is a huge thrill
for me
um that said
um it's all about in between the Innings
I mean it's a different kind of it's a
different kind of Rush than what we're
used to but it's it's challenging a
Caribbean Resort
the staff in the in the Bahamas is very
very relaxed and it's not what I'm used
to so like you know I'm an I'm in New
York time but the one thing that the one
thing that it teaches you is that not
everything has to be in a rush it's like
but you definitely have to
um sort of change your your stopwatch so
to speak and if dinner takes a little
bit longer to get to the customer
actually no one cares and it's the one
thing that I had to learn it was like
everybody's relaxed even the customers
so it's nice
so this is the one you just basically
kill everybody with yeah it's like a
setup
the photographer is shooting me eat this
one this is the this is the month this
is like the moment right
it's almost you know too much
no I I can see I can see them lurking in
the in the shadows
even when you smell this when it hurts
oh oh
yeah and this is crazy
all right
no I know I gotta join you actually
what is the
that one takes you bro takes your breath
away
I can't see because I'm crying but what
is the chili here
Smoky chipotle peppers oh it's it's it's
a pepper extract yeah yeah you know you
know that chili pepper extract it's like
so concentrated man yeah just pure
this is a lot of hot sauce that's this
this is literally two lifetime supplies
like who buys two of those right in the
over the course of their lives I'll take
a six pack of this it's like like have
it with every meal
so naturally this show invites a lot of
conversations
so it's 10 000 hours you know
I can my time half of my tongue hasn't
does not have any Feeling Anymore
it's actually a rather poetic segue
because you know this show it invites a
lot of conversations about spice
antidotes notably ice cream which I know
holds a very special place in your heart
from Frozen treat dummies like myself
like what even is the difference between
Ice Cream versus gelato versus sorbet
sorbet is is
has no dairy in it
so basically it's just like a very very
smooth most of the time it's like a a
fruity concoction
sugar water doesn't doesn't have you
know cream so to speak or or an unglaze
actually gelato has less butter fat in
it than regular ice cream and when you
look at it and taste it you would never
think that because of the denseness and
the creaminess of it all but that's
really that's really the the case when
I'm in Italy
I have a really hard time passing any
gelato shop I hit like I feel like I hit
every single one of them this is a very
hot sauce this thing right here is hot
see this is this is like everything else
right here you're like oh yeah just yeah
this one's nice and yellow this one is
orange this is green this is herbaceous
and then you throw in the bomb and
nothing else matters it's just violent
it's just violent
I'm in pain
it's hard to taste
this one after that one but I'm tasting
some smokiness there we're 90 done
I want to tell you something yeah I'm
going to let you in a secret sure if you
notice I haven't had any water right
I don't think water is a good idea no
yeah yeah I mean it's it's it looks
amazing especially when you taste
something like the bomb but it kind of
swigs everything it just moves around
and to me the dairy is the key and you
were like bigger you're like is this
whole milk is this whole milk before you
know we don't often have people double
check that but that's the that's the
milk to go for in a city because when
I'm in Los Angeles I can't even get
whole milk oh my god when these are
guests to become more and more famous
the milks become weirder and more exotic
it's crazy like you go to a coffee shop
in L.A they're like I'm like whole milk
oat milk no whole milk
and they look at me like are you sure
let me check in the back to see if we
have it because nobody drinks it no no
we gotta keep it alive keeping it alive
today
can you tell me about the time that
Drake brought you to cook for the cast
of Saturday Night Live but all accounts
a big moment the animals the best in all
history
well I don't know about that definitely
a big moment in my life I was in Toronto
cooking at a friend of mine's restaurant
a chef named susral Lee and uh Drake was
one of the investors of the restaurant
and uh there was a club downstairs that
uh sort of like his own private bar that
he had downstairs in the restaurant and
it was an after party there afterwards
so I got to talk to him a little while
incredibly nice guy
we exchanged numbers
and um about three days later
um he texted me and he's like do you
have a second I want to ask you a
question and I said sure So I get on the
phone with him he's like look
it's kind of quiet but I'm gonna be the
host and the musical guest for SNL this
week and I want to do something really
great for them I'm like great so how can
I help you and he's like will you cook
for them
and I was like oh uh okay sure when he's
like tomorrow night
so I called Erica she's here who is the
head of publicity for Food Network and
I was like I need the kitchen I need
staff and I need trucks
because we're gonna make a bunch of
paellas and a bunch of other all kinds
of food and this and that and um and you
know we got it done we went there and it
was a surprise for the cast a couple of
cast members who I'd known before saw me
in the hallway like what are you doing
here like are you in one of the bits I'm
like no just walking around with my
apron on
[Music]
so this is the last dab experience
you want to know how this came about so
yeah basically there's this uh this is
spicy yeah so the guy grew the Carolina
Reaper which for many years was the
hottest pepper in the world right yeah
his name is smoking Ed
and uh
we actually enlisted his services to put
together this one
this is a Caroline no so
he has another pepper in his War chest
called the pepper X so this one is like
featuring The pepperax hence the
experience you know so this is worse
than the Carolina Reaper you know to
each their own I think like once you get
to a certain altitude it's just it's all
scrambled when you put the dab on it are
you supposed to eat the dab too
okay but
right
that's hot that like sort of earthy
fruity
pepper situation
but the good news is it's over I'm still
eating I know I know
[Music]
I know
but
it's been a harrowing Journey not only
through the wings but also your career
the highs the lows but one blind spot
we'd Miss not to mention
Burgers you know you're not only a
massive fan but also a purveyor is there
a right or wrong answer to which kind of
cheese is best on a burger
yes there is
American all the way
and every Chef will tell you the same
thing American cheese is just the right
cheese and also I always say at Bobby's
Burger Palace it was always a sign that
said Bobby says melt the cheese
completely because a lot of times
you go to a restaurant and they don't
melt the cheese completely it doesn't
taste the same there's something about
that melted cheese kind of just dripping
off the burger onto your bun Etc that
just makes it taste that much better
Gunda head
best fast food chain Burger in your
opinion
let's see fast food chain Burger
I guess I'm gonna have to go with in and
out we'll set it in stone Gospel
According to box okay and look at you
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life all right uh make
sure you watch uh triple threat it's
actually called Bobby's triple threat I
don't like saying my own name while I'm
talking about it so I'll just call it
Triple Threat uh nine o'clock Thursday
nights I'm sorry that's Tuesdays
that's all right 30 years later still
got two time slots unlocked nine o'clock
Tuesday nights on Food Network uh make
sure you check it out and of course Beat
Bobby Flay uh we're in season 9 000.
we've done 500 episodes uh 10 years in
Thursday nights uh 9 p.m on Food Network
I'll see you there hot sauce in hand
thank you
[Applause]
wow
I have to say like I liked so many of
the flavors of the hot sauce yeah I mean
they really and I and I think like
that's that's one of the things I wanted
to talk about a little bit just as a
cook that you know it's not just hot you
know it's it's there's there's lots of
lots of bounds and lots of flavors here
some of them they just blow your mouth
away and then some of them are just
beautiful Symphonies of flavor it's
great well symphony is a flavor you hear
that Chris
that's the bullseye that's what he's
going for that's from Bobby Flay
this is delicious
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans with an announcement truth
or dab the game now has a brand new
refresh Edition that's right if you
already had the original truth or dab
game you can now get even more hotter
questions with the refresh Edition the
game is simple answer deeply personal
and potentially awkward questions or
face the Wrath of the last app that's
right both editions of The Game feature
a mini bottle of the last dab hot sauce
check out the description below to see
where you can pick up hot ones truth or
dab the game or visit wildertoys.com
[Music]
foreign